oh
oh eddie i hope you're happy mate this
is not this is not okay
i didn't say you're hurt this much
my name's ricky stevens and i'm a window
cleaner i've been
doing bodybuilding for the last four
years
basically i want to become a little
beast
[Music]
i do i tell you what you're you're a
stocky guy mate well come on
i know you've done a little bit of a bit
of bodybuilding you've been on stage as
well
yeah yeah i've compete competed for the
last three four years and i've got a
picture of yourself
wow chiseled yeah
that was the best i've ever looked and
then i was basically told my best wasn't
good enough right and i was devastated
with bodybuilding
you can train your whole life it's
someone's opinion yeah
whether you are better than the man
still stood next to you yeah and i think
that's [ __ ]
yeah that's fair comment i don't quite
know how we're gonna beast your body
because it looks like you've beasted
yourself quite enough
but i've got a good team with me so luke
chris want to get here please guys
we know how to beast each other and we
know how to beat other people
what do you want out of this i need to
exercise my demons so
i want to leave them with no doubt that
i am the best person on that stage
i want to become the little beast what
do you want to do guys should we put it
through the test
my opinion would be three compound lifts
squat bench
and deadlift
[Music]
[Music]
this is pushing it
[Music]
come on
[Music]
most i've ever done was 170. i've nearly
passed out let's get it
[Music]
so the back of your head goes purple
[Music]
let's get it now let's get angry
picture and hopefully in six weeks we're
going to see a mass monster return to us
so get your ass against that wall there
for me mate okay front
take 90 degree to your right and then
the other way ricky it's been a pleasure
to meet you buddy
very much very much six weeks thank you
take care man
tell you what he impressed me today man
that was uh some of those lifts were
gnarly but he did him you've sent him
some hard targets mate oh he wants to be
the mini beast
he's got it he's gotta pick up the pace
about you guys but i'm
hungry yeah me too good day
punch
so it's the morning after the day before
and
i still have to pinch myself by me and
eddie it's given me
definitely a renewed fire in my belly
[Music]
it's always a good time pushing you and
believing in you
now if you don't think that of yourself
how are you meant to how are you meant
to push on
[Music]
well mentally i'm starting to actually
believe that i can actually do
the uh the target set for me
[Music]
hey ricky i've been following your
progress and it looks like you've been
smashing it we're about halfway through
now sending chris and luke to check up
on you
and give you some support big love the
beast
hi rick hello mate all right how are you
doing honey who's this
yeah with the transition from the from
the bodybuilding training has that been
for your head
i have to find myself i'm stopping
myself from training it feels like i'm
under training how have you found
the the change in the food you've got me
to eat chocolate for breakfast
yeah this program's probably come at a
perfect time because i was just lacking
that structure
i'm starting to believe that i can do
better than i thought i did
and especially with this sort of
training now the thing i was lacking the
most probably on stage was thickness
yeah what's the next step i need to get
back on stage i need to
do better than i did last time and what
happens ricky if
if that doesn't happen just because you
fail at first doesn't mean you're going
to fail again
you can always you can always go again
you can always try again
they say dogs and owners there you go
yeah they look the same face wise as
well
[Laughter]
he's disciplined i'll give him that and
he's social because of this
he deserves anything he gets we've just
seen ricky
um he seems very motivated and maybe a
little bit
worried about where ricky will go from
here
if he doesn't achieve what he wants to
achieve
so when luke got to my house the other
day
he said i should get my hip flexors done
didn't say it would hurt this much
oh eddie i hope you're happy mate this
is not this is not okay
wow
[Music]
hey ricky how are you buddy you okay you
can't go wrong with me
let's face it mate that sounds that
sounds amazing so me i mean you talk
about this fourth place and you want
that first place position
when i started out strong man my first
world strongest mind i didn't even make
the final
and then my sixth attempt i won the
world's strongest man but trust me
it was those five failures that made me
the man i am today
it's the failure i've seen it now it's
investment in disguise
because i'm learning more from that
failure than i would have ever had
if i achieved my goals early
so ricky's a very spartish guy you know
he's whatever you say or or do for him
he'll probably put his own little tweak
on it and that's the feeling they get
from ricky so
will he stick to the program probably
not will he stick to the diet
probably not you know what i could be
proved wrong and ricky could be a real
success story
so the reason for me wanting to get onto
this show and
to give me that sense of achievement
to get back self-confidence the only
failure
that you get is when you don't build
upon
something you haven't achieved if you
stop if you quit
that's the true failure so irrespective
of what happens
at the end i'm happy
because i've achieved what i wanted to
i've got that sense of
self belief back i'm gonna get where i
want to go
and maybe further
[Applause]
you look pretty jacked you do
with this transformation that he's done
how do you think this is gonna affect
him do you think he's going to go back
to the bodybuilding or do you think he's
just going to carry on do his own thing
i'm personally not quite sure what way
he will go but
what i do know is give him new direction
um and again it's giving them new goals
that new drive
and it's made him realise what he's
capable of as well i think
i think he really needed it
[Music]
3.6 kilograms on in body weight three
and a half of which is linked
which is actually meant that his body
fat has dropped every slightly half a
percent it's a lot of hard work
and dedication to put weight on and
actually bring your body fat down
what we're testing on today barbell
squat that was the area where i had the
biggest
uh area for improvement how'd you feel
sweet we're going to do a big bb
uh i think you'll be surprised all right
let's get to it
[Music]
all
[Music]
well i'm intrigued i mean you've done so
well with this manufacturer see what we
do on the deadlift your pb last time is
210 can you convert it yeah let's go for
it
okay
over two and a half times bodyweight
deadlift which puts you in a very elite
group
on the planet and it genuinely does the
beast and the beast
before pictures let's do the actors
this is what ricky looked like six weeks
ago
and then you go today you'll see the
difference in his chest
abdominals are sticking out more and
he's happier
thank you guys so much i cannot say i
thankfully off of
everyone's input and help us it's giving
me a new outlook
and giving me a new determination which
which i
really like yeah i'm really really happy
that was amazing well done man thank you
very much well done
and the thing what i like about ricky is
he came to us with a bit of a plateau he
just seems as though he lost his passion
yeah
not really getting out anywhere with it
and then he's found this inner strength
and he's come back three and a half
kilos heavier and four kilos heavier
i mean not only is he strong physically
but mentally as well and
commended for that you see i'm smiling
i'm smiling again and i haven't
smiled after achieving something in the
gym for a very long time
the the lifts i got today i didn't dream
i could get so
i feel like i've definitely turned into
a little beast
you've been beasted
you